aussi aux états unis le candidat
républicain à la maison blanche bob dole
a terminé son débat télévisé avec bill
clinton en s'adressant ainsi aux
téléspectateurs américains si vous
voulez vraiment vous engager
rejoignez-moi sur internet proposition
tout à fait impensable en france où
seuls 2 % des ménages sont équipés
d'ordinateurs domestique un rapport du
commissariat au plan vient de mettre en
lumière le sous-équipement français ont
réseaux informatiques ça sera le thème
ce soir de notre dossier préparé par
françoise laborde et frédéric cros ta
face au succès mondial d'internet les
français ne sont pas très nets
téléphone télévision
ordinateur bienvenue dans le monde
virtuel et faute français s'aventure
moins de deux cent mille foyers sont
abonnés au réseau internet aux etats
unis ils sont venus millions à surfer
sur le web selon la formule consacrée
pour la plupart des petits français
l'ordinateur n'est souvent qu'une
matière apprise à l'école avec l'aide
parfois hésitante du professeur aux
états unis l'ordinateur personnel est
obligatoire au même titre que les livres
scolaires en france bien sûr le taux
d'équipement est ridiculement bas mais
ça on va pas faire une jupette
de bourbourg aider à la vente des pc
c'est absurde il est vrai que le prix
d'un pc d'un ordinateur reste élevé
alors que le minitel distribué quasi
gratuitement a engendré en france
d'autres habitudes des les populaires
alors il est rudimentaire il parle pas
il n'y a pas de vidéo l'élan mais il est
populaire il est entré dans les moeurs
et il ya un nombre très important de
services sur l'unité et de penser que
les 18 millions d'utilisateurs d'une
telle vont se verser sur l'internet
c'est à peu près aussi idiot que dire on
va verser lammerville teyrannais dans
une tasse de thé dans cette salle à
boston on gère une partie des réseaux
téléphoniques du monde et donc
d'internet 64% des ordinateurs raccordés
au réseau se trouve aux états unis en
france le sous équipement des foyers
n'explique pas tout les français ont une
relation difficile il avec la
communication au réseau une réticence
quasi culturelle respectée que je pense
que c'est uniquement culturel ce n'est
certainement pas technologique la france
est un des pays les plus avancés du
monde sûrement pas économique votre pays
est en bonne santé c'est à 100% que
vous avez une vision si traditionnels si
hiérarchisé de la société vous est le
pays le moins ouvert internet les jeunes
comme les yeux nous présent corps à qui
cette culture
réticences culturelles sans doute
barrière linguistique sûrement l'accès à
internet demande quelques notions
d'informatique et de vraies
connaissances en anglais en france
internet a d'abord été considéré comme
un gadget ou pire comme un instrument
incontrôlable avec ses scandales réseau
de prostitution piratage de livres ou
trafic de médicaments aux états unis il
est avant tout considéré comme un outil
de conquête commerciale aux formidables
possibilités
aujourd'hui pourtant certaines
entreprises françaises se lancent à
commencer par les grands voyagistes qui
proposent leur catalogue sur le réseau
mondial via internet donc c'est pas du
tout un gadget c'est un plus pour le
client et ça permet aussi à notre groupe
de développer notre activité
internationale et d'être en contact avec
tous les clients au niveau mondial
aujourd'hui en france les adeptes
d'internet se retrouvent le plus souvent
au café un peu comme autrefois on a les
tirs regarder la télévision faute de
poste à domicile ici se croiser des
jeunes et des moins jeunes
tous sont branchés sur l'horizon
mondiale dans une tradition bien de chez
nous le bistrot de quoi réconcilier les
français et l'ordinateur